on the only rest day of US Championship
grandmasters ray Robson and Parvati
Laura came out to the white Davis Tennis
Center in forest park to get a little
fitness in chess players have become
increasingly aware of the importance of
physical conditioning especially when
each game they play might last for 25
hours and they must play daily
walking keeping the really famous
players like Bobby Fischer or capacity
and I think Magnus plays so get like a
lot of the Chancellor's also play tennis
when I play tennis is almost like
everyday so normally i think you know
over time they'll improve my stamina i
think yeah over the past year i haven't
really gotten as tired north end of term
and so it's my department yeah tennis is
a fun game obviously i play trust so i
don't have anywhere near as much time in
essence i was like but still it's fun to
get out every so often a play for it
seems like nowadays i'm liking the past
a lot of top players they're in pretty
good shape whether they play
soccer various sports I think there's
something to be said for the fact that
trust requires a lot of energy and so
being a good physical shape can only
have added benefits as opposed to being
harmful later on in the players rest day
they boarded a bus to busch stadium
where they enjoyed fine food and drinks
than 13 sweet along with Hall of Famers
Whitey Herzog and Bob Gibbs night many
players had to be shown the rules of
baseball but we're intrigued to learn
about things like home runs strikeouts
in the light let's say this guy picked
it up off the ground and it's this guy's
running I tag I have the ball in my hand
I actually tagged him with the ball oh
yeah then he's out like there's a ball
that one is well this is my first time
much for the baseball game and a lot of
fun enjoying the game I like a lot of
sports I'm a big soccer fan and I know
soccer hockey I know this feels very
well but first time to baseball games
definitely enjoying it I think I kind of
got an idea the rules and I remembered
everything I have like the I don't know
all the details yet about the games but
I know the future in the post the home
run
you